le 7-8 encore ensemble jusqu'à 19 heures
si vous nous suivez en direct une
vingtaine de minutes cette partie avec
jean-luc ghislain le responsable de la
croix rouge à saint quentin et jean-marc
rennais l'organisateur du pari
versailles bonsoir à tous les deux on va
revenir sur vos actualités respectives
l'ouverture d'une halte détente pour les
personnes atteintes de la maladie
d'alzheimer donc pour la croix-rouge et
puis la nouvelle édition de cette course
à pied entre la capitale et la cité
royale
justement pratiquez-vous la course à
pied de vous adepte des marathons ou des
footings nouveau avons posé la question
oui je pratique un petit peu la course à
pied parce que j'estime que c'est
important pour le corps tout simplement
que ça fait du bien et puis bah quand on
est jeune autant profiter oui toutes les
semaines pour la santé non je ne
pratique pas la course attire manque de
temps et problèmes de genoux aussi voilà
oui et je la pratique et pour faire de
l'exercice tout simplement non parce que
moi je
j'ai un problème de surpoids donc c'est
pas trop conseiller pour l'instant
peut-être plus tard mais mon mari il
vient de se faire opérer du dos donc ces
morts aussi pour nous c'est un bon moyen
un moyen ludique ou en baladant à
travers le paysage on fait du sport et
on fait du bien à son corps et puis
surtout pour nous les jeunes basse et
surtout gratuit voilà puis c'est un
phénomène de société aussi il faut dire
malheureusement non parce que je suis je
suis seul avec ma fille donc je
travaille donc à mon grand regret je ne
peux pas faire de sport enfin je n'ai
pas je n'ai pas le temps de faire du
sport
oui je la pratique et ça me détend et
puis ça donne une grande liberté voilà
phénomène de société
de plus en plus de monde courait ce qui
explique sans doute le succès de cette
35e édition du paris versailles
les inscriptions ont été bouclés il ya
cinq semaines déjà depuis le 24 août il
n'est plus possible de s'inscrire
c'est un record vous avez battu cette
année c'est la première fois on arrive à
boucler les inscriptions largement
plusieurs semaines avant avant la course
vous êtes à peu près à 25 mille
participants ou des 25000 enfin 24 1809
exactement à ce jour et effectivement
enfin il ya plusieurs effets aussi l
effet internet qui fait que les gens se
préoccupent beaucoup plus facilement et
plus tôt de leur inscription donc ça
serait beaucoup plus tôt donc c'est
devenu un rendez vous incontournable
forcément ça paris versailles c'est un
rendez vous incontournable mais souvent
différents cirques eux on a fait des
analyses de suivi de nos coureurs on a
beaucoup de coureurs nouveau tous les
ans n'en revient pas chaque année
forcément pas forcément chaque année
donc bon ce qui vient revient mais bon
et puis il ya un effet de connaissance
de de proximité et souvent notre course
courte 16 km on est loin d'un
semi-marathon et en fait c'est la
première course que les gens à bord dans
six ans a fait un petit peu mal c'est un
petit peu compliqué mais quand même
c'est pas très long donc ça va être une
heure et demie d'efforts et une heure et
demie d'efforts maintenant sa bourde
assez facilement comme c'est évoqué tout
à l'heure dans le reportage une heure et
demie d'efforts quel parcours justement
par la tour eiffel on va tout droit vers
versailles vers l'ouest longe la seine
monte sur moudon côte des gardes
traversée de la forêt de meudon forêt de
chaville forêt de vélizy fred giroflées
et on arrive
sur l'avenue de paris plein plein face
au château de versailles 500 mètres de
l'arrivée
un petit aperçu justement du parcours
voile alors là en voiture ça va
forcément beaucoup plus vite ça va plus
vite c'est un petit peu le parcours de
voir la traversée les participants
quelques 25 milles pour cette 35e
édition du paris versailles vous avez
mentionné la cote des gardes c'est le
premier obstacle 6 km avec l'aquilon
bassène donc forcément c'est plat et
c'est un vrai un vrai gros obstacle
puisque il ya des montées à alors de 12%
donc c'est une vraie difficulté et c'est
souvent d'ailleurs pour les provinciaux
un petit peu une surprise voire même des
parisiens qui en espace est coté ce côté
de paris un peu surprise pour déballer
pour assurer sa tournée parcours après
la côte une descente aussi mais qu'un
peu moins long mais qui est quand même
très difficile en course à pied où je
trouve qu'on souffre plus dans une
descente que dans une montée et puis
viroflay ya une très belle côte puis
l'arrivée sur l'avenue de paris est
quand même en faux plat montant vent de
face comme on dit est ce que vaut le
courrier vous l'avez déjà gelé couru
bien sûr il ya très longtemps
celle ci et d'autres courses bien sûr m
et aujourd'hui c'est un peu moins un peu
moins j'ai fait quelques marathons et le
dernier j'ai fait plus d'un an j'ai un
peu du mal à récupérer
il ya vingt-cinq mille personnes qui
vont participer beaucoup viennent pour
s'amuser pour la détente pour le loisir
il ya aussi quelques champions des
athlètes des champions qui viennent bien
sûr dont je pense qu'une caution
une vraie grosse course et les deux
circuits a forcément 25 mille corps
anonymes qu'il faut auxquels il faut
être très attentif ont-ils bien sûr tout
ce qu'on peut leur apporter comme
service et puis la notoriété aussi de
l'épreuve c'est forcément la course
élite actuellement et la course élite
les premiers mètres 46 minutes donc
l'effritement des larrons champions
notamment
enfin j'espère qu'il reviendra pour
gagner c'est des natifs meftah qui est
français donc et et qui avait eu au
téléphone cette semaine il a fait une
très mauvaise performance and à londres
dont il aimerait bien effacer cette
mauvaise performance il avait gagné il
ya deux ans chez nous qui sera présent
qui participent à la course alors vous
l'avez dit c'est la partie et lille ça
veut dire qu'il ya plusieurs départs
comment ça va se passer pour ceux qui
veulent assister parce que maintenant on
peut plus s'inscrire faudra attendre
l'année prochaine alors 25 mille
coureurs c'est énorme c'est beaucoup
donc leur éviter pour éviter que tout le
monde parte en même temps et que sa pose
et dernier en difficulté notamment dans
les traversées des forêts qui sont des
espaces pas très large on fait en sorte
qu'on fait partir que 350 coureurs par
minute et sa durée a pas mal mais ça
dure une heure
ça fait à peu près les 22 23 mille
coureurs classés puisque il ya toujours
d'autres ont mis deux personnes qui
viennent pas courir et donc c'est vrai
que ça dure une heure mais en fait
maintenant avec les systèmes
électroniques on a le temps réel de
départ et d'arrivée
bien évidemment grâce à des camps de
métrage électronique et ensuite
classement général mais chacun court
vraiment pour sa propre performance et
en fait je sais ce qui est important
c'est ça c'est tout va recourir dans de
très bonnes conditions et on fait tout
pour que ça le soit paris versailles 35e
édition ce sera le 30 septembre
et puis la météo forcément météo france
qui annonce à un temps alors j'ai
regardé ça 9 degrés le matin 18 l'après
midi est ce que ce sont de bonnes
conditions très lentement et sûrement
18 c'est juste ça c'est presque chaud ce
qu'on aille vers midi mais c'est bien
c'est mieux quand qu'aujourd'hui
notamment que les jours précédents
et je crois que c'est évidemment la
météo est clémente pour le week-end du
samedi au lundi donc c'est très bien
pour nous merci de nous parler de ça
donc sous les meilleurs auspices en tout
va bien se passer pour cette nouvelle
édition du paris versailles